one of my favorite people in the entire
world ever in the history of time is amy
sedaris
i got to meet you on rupaul's drag race
that's right and i sort of just sort of
stuck to you like a barnacle ever since
i was glued to you on that episode glue
this one amy sedaris okay i'm gonna ask
you as many questions as i can now these
questions are meaningless and pointless
okay great cool let's start
what skill do you wish you had oh typing
no even in movies when i see people and
they're doing this thing i won the um
keyboarding class in high school i won
the fastest type room oh really really
and you don't have to look down
you know you remember what time did you
go to bed last night 1 30. what time you
get up in the morning today i got up at
eight do the math carry the one that's
only seven hours
this is the most important question i'll
ask today waffles or pancakes waffles
yeah um follow up i like the name
pancake
but waffle's a good name for like a
hamster
right i can't argue with logic do you
believe in ghosts i do i felt one before
you know like pinch my toe and i heard
it sounded like a fluttering a bat sleep
but everyone just thinks you're crazy
like aunt clara ooh did that chair move
they all think i'm crazy
i'm crazy
do you a hundred percent yeah okay there
you go i think we have we have to go
somewhere yeah we do have you seen or
felt a ghost no they're all ghosting me
you're so transparent
what is the um last show you binge
watched i'm binge watching succession
right now it's so good right yeah are
you ready for the new season yeah i'm
ready i'm almost done with season two
but you're super famous don't they just
send you advanced copies of it
are you kidding me i'm not kidding
what's your go-to coffee order just
black coffee i know boring oh god
yeah well do you need a friend i do i
need a gun
okay i'll take you guys i'll put milk in
it but i'm into just iced flat coffee
right now i'm gonna take you and show
you the wonder of dairy okay okay
um amy sedaris that's all the questions
i have for you that's it this is the
easiest interview you'll have today oh
my god that was fun
[Music]